ETIAN KONIGSBURG:
So hi, everybody.
My name's Etian Konigsburg.
I'm a frontend
software architect here
at the "New York Times".
Today I'm going to
be talking about
the very real history of our
web performance efforts here
at the "New York Times".
Before I dive in, I
wanted to share with you
this tweet by Steve
Souders himself.
If you're not familiar
Steve Souders,
it's the place to
start when you're
talking about web performance.
He tweeted, "Is
performance of 'the Web'
getting better or worse?
My past week was
painfully slow, marred
by top sites w/bad WebPerf.
Is it too hard?"
I don't know if the "New York
Times" was among the sites
that Steve was
having trouble with.
We've known that we've had a
little bit of a performance
problem.
I like to think that
he's checking our site
and he's actually complaining
for real that our site is slow
so that we make it faster him.
But I'm going to get
back to this question
about whether it's too hard.
So while I was
preparing for this talk,
I was thinking that this
is a very real story.
And it reminded me of a
GEICO ad from about 2006
that I just kind of
wanted to share with you.
So just give me one sec to play.
[VIDEO PLAYBLACK]
-Paula Sala is a real GEICO
customer, not an actor.
So to help tell her story,
we hired that announcer guy
from the movies.
-When the storm hit, both our
cars were totally under water.
-In a world where both of our
-We thought it would take
forever to get some help.
-But a new wind
was about to blow.
-With GEICO, we had
our check in two days.
-Payback.
This time, it's for real.
-GEICO.
Real service.
Real savings.
ETIAN KONIGSBURG: So I thought
about doing this entire talk
in movie announcer voice.
I didn't think I'd be able to
keep it up all the way through.
Colt is actually
the expert at that.
So you should check out
his talk on National Talk
Like A Pirate Day.
That was actually really great.
Kudos.
So in a world of static pages.
Pages on our website
are published basically
like you would a newspaper.
Somebody hits a button, the
content goes through templates
and is written to disk.
And we mix it with a
proprietary language
that we compile to give a
little bit of dynamicism
on the server side.
And it was fast.
We have about 1 million of
these static pages since 2004.
And re-publishing them is
really not an option for us.
If hypothetically it
took about five seconds
to re-publish one
of these pages,
5 million seconds I think
comes out to about two months.
We can't be doing that
every time we make a change.
So what ends up happening is
it's extremely hard for us
to change markup once
it's been published.
And every time we
make a change, it's
only present from the
day we deployed onward,
which means we have an
unknown number of permutations
of these markups to handle
and support over time.
So our frontend assets,
our JavaScript and CSS,
have to handle all of
these permutations.
And in order to be able
to change these files,
since we can't change the
asset path because the HTML is
static, we have to
keep the time to live,
the cache expiration timeout,
very low on these files, which
is a performance bad practice.
And we also don't really
know what pages on the site
call which assets in general.
So I want to talk
about our CSS history.
We didn't really
have a CSS framework,
which means we have a
lot of repetitive styles.
Files were imported
basically as needed.
Style sheets approached.
The import limits in IE, 31
total and maybe up to three
nested levels deep.
There was inconsistent
load style.
We were using link tags in
one case, and right after it,
using a style tag with
an @import directive.
And basically, we also have
to deal with web producers who
who go through, and they're
able to modify the look
and feel of our page on the
fly as the news happens.
So they can be dropped
into our content system
and appear anywhere on the page.
In the JavaScript department,
JavaScript was very ad hoc.
Since most of the dynamicism
was on the server side,
we basically used
JS basically as
needed to fix
cross-browser issues,
to do widgets that
respond to events
by the user in the browser.
Most of the variables
and functions are global.
Script tags are dropped
wherever they were needed.
You would define a new
div, leave it empty,
and you'd put a script
tag right after it.
We didn't defer execution,
another performance no no.
We didn't have a DOM
framework to handle
any cross-browser functionality.
That framework war happened and
we still hadn't picked one yet.
Some words on images.
Basically, the UI images
that are part of a product
would get uploaded
individually to production.
You could easily forget
how to do that when
you were deploying,
so they would
go missing for a little while.
Our content photography
is extremely hard for us
to optimize.
We have a lot of pride
in our photography.
There's a lot of resistance
in making them smaller
and not featuring them
as largely on our pages.
We did some experiments
with lossless compression.
We actually, for
color novices, we
noticed some colors changing
in whatever these tools were.
There's a whole department here
that does color correction,
and the red walls don't
appear in their area
so that they don't have a
little bit of red dilution
on their screens to do
this color correction.
It's basically a manual
process to resize these images.
We have a lot of them.
And in order for them to be
fast and have them be smaller,
people have to cut them and make
sure they don't crop something
out of the picture.
Because it's manual, it
doesn't happen a lot.
Other concerns for the business.
We have these
editorial constraints.
Like I mentioned
earlier, producers
have a need to adjust based on
what's happening in the news.
So we use this
freeform module where
they can drop any
bit of HTML code.
It doesn't even have
to be balanced tags,
so this can easily
mess up our page.
But they have the
freedom to do that.
And we have to be able to handle
styles and scripts occurring
in them.
And ads, of course.
They're top-level
objects in our DOM.
They're not treated
in any special way.
They bring their own copies
of DOM frameworks in.
We get older versions of jQuery.
We saw an ad that tried
to encapsulate prototype
which, if you're familiar
with how prototype.js works,
it modifies built-in
objects in the browser.
You can't actually
contain it in a box,
so it didn't really work.
Ads animate as
soon as they load.
We get a lot of painting
issues when animations
happen while the
page is loading.
And basically, they are
higher in the DOM order
as the page is loading than
our own logo on the homepage.
You'll see two ads,
and then you'll
see our logo if you
look at the source.
So just to caveat
all of this history,
it wasn't really
entirely all bad.
We do use a CDN.
We've had Akamai for
a number of years.
It's been great.
We did turn GSIP on in 2007.
The bandwidth savings
were actually immediate,
and there were a lot
of really happy people
as soon as we did that.
But it wasn't on
previously, and it's worth
mentioning that
we did turn it on.
So a new wind for
our efforts, and what
we were trying to do starting
in 2009 to make the site faster.
2009 was the year
we were focusing
on tools and libraries.
We basically built a new build
system for frontend files.
And this was our first foray
into doing automatic builds.
We used to manually
untar uncompressed files
in production.
And we were actually pulling
changes from version control as
opposed to somebody's
home directory.
They would arrange the files the
way they wanted them to appear,
we would package them up, and
someone would unpackage it.
Now it's coming from
version control directly.
There were
semi-stateful rollbacks.
There was a rollback
mechanism, but you could really
only roll back the latest one.
If you tried to roll
back any before that,
you would end up in an unknown
state, and that was really bad.
But the really
exciting bit of it
was that there were
hooks for build scripts.
And we can expand on this
process basically dynamically.
So we did just that for our CSS.
It was the first system
to use those new hooks.
And we wrote a bunch
proprietary scripts
to not only unravel the ad
import directives to make
one concatenated file,
we wrote a script
to also try and to remove
some of the white space
and the comments.
This was all downstream
from development work, which
is also a really good point.
We didn't want our
developers to feel
that they couldn't comment
their work adequately.
While we were
doing this, we were
working on our CSS framework.
We took the concepts
from our design,
and we turned them
into these base files
that can be used
across the site.
We split code into
reusable modules
and actually tried to
reuse them in a sane way.
We aim to have a single entry
point at the top of the page.
While we're doing
this, we were also
trying to lock down
our JS development.
We introduced a
top-level namespace
called NYTD, and
the module pattern,
also called the immediately
invoked function expression.
This is a great way to wrap all
your variables in a closure,
although thanks to Colt,
I'm now afraid of closures.
We introduced prototype.js
as a DOM library.
This one bullet
point doesn't really
reflect the amount of
meetings and discussions
and debates and fights we
had over this decision.
But prototype.js
won out in the end.
We also tried to write our
own proprietary asynchronous
JavaScript loader in the
days before RequireJS.
LABjs, any of these
loaders, they didn't exist.
We tried to write our own.
It didn't really work.
It became a synchronous
JavaScript loader.
So we started with our
homepage, and there's
a number of reasons why.
It's published very
frequently, so this problem
with legacy markup really
doesn't become an issue.
It gets the most traffic,
so it has the potential
to save people the
most amount of time.
It has an isolated
implementation.
Basically, if
something went wrong,
nothing would go wrong on
other parts of the site.
And it's viewed very
heavily internally.
If something were
really bad, it'd
get noticed before it
got out into production.
So November, 2009, we
put our CSS optimizations
on the homepage.
It saved 25 HTTP connections to
what are very small CSS files.
The first paint occurred
a whole second earlier,
and the homepage
really felt faster.
And we are very happy by this.
So in 2010, we wanted to
continue these efforts.
The CSS framework
basically rolled out
to our section
and article pages.
Again, we were focusing
on a single entry point.
But we never optimized them.
There were some concerns with
these proprietary scripts.
And it turns out later,
when we did an audit,
that we were right
to be concerned.
There were references
to missing files.
There were @import cycles.
A would include B
include C include A.
And if you're ever curious
about what the browser does
to get out of that, I still
don't know the answer.
And there were syntax errors.
There were styles
not getting applied
because they were
typed improperly.
So we decided to build a
new JS build system in 2010.
We forked the codebase.
We wanted to create
a clean build.
And only code that was
modular and namespaced
would be able to
be in this build.
Basically, we have these
manifests of files that had
an @import-like syntax in a JS
comment so that they would be
inert if the build
process failed.
We used YUI Compressor
for minification.
We no longer want to
write our own scripts.
This was well supported
at the time, so why not?
We were focusing
on two build files,
one at the top,
one at the bottom.
If you're familiar with
the best practices,
they say that you're
supposed to put
your JS at the
bottom of the page.
So why did we have
them at the top?
If you remember that editors
can put JavaScript on the page.
If we wanted them to
use our frameworks,
it had to be there before they
could actually run their code.
So we put stuff at
the top to make sure
that that wouldn't
break anything.
This build process
was executed manually,
so it didn't see
widespread usage.
It's basically almost
only on the homepage.
And now we have two code
bases and still no automatic
build process.
But when we did launch these
JS changes to the homepage,
it was pretty drastic.
We got a 50% speedup,
six seconds down from 12.
We were very excited by that.
So 2011 was a bit
of a slow year.
As you might remember if you're
fans of "The New York Times",
we introduced digital
subscriptions in 2011.
So resourcing for
this kind of work
was really, really
hard to come by.
Oh, hello.
I don't know what I just did.
All right.
There were efforts to optimize
our analytics packaging.
We have a lot of
analytics packages,
and they were kind of doing
some really bad stuff.
They got aborted,
mostly because we
were afraid to break
these actual reports.
We wanted to make sure
that the business was
able to analyze
things correctly,
so we didn't continue that.
So we used a series of code
reviews and style guides
to make sure that
we were enforcing
good standards
and best practices
to keep the status quo.
But at the end of 2011,
we made the decision.
We decided to
replace prototype.js
with jQuery sitewide.
And as you can imagine,
this is really, really hard.
We needed both of them to
coexist during the transition.
We weren't going to rewrite
everything and launch
a new site on a new
framework all at once,
so we needed both
of them to basically
be around while we did this.
But in 2012, a group
of five developers
basically set out to try
and excise prototype.js
from article pages.
And we were making really,
really excellent progress.
Things were going great.
Hours and hours of work.
And then we found out there
were some inline scripts that
made references to prototype.js.
And if you remember that we have
these static pages with markup
that we can't change,
we really have no idea
of what's calling prototype.js
in inline scripts.
And so therefore, we're not
ever able to remove prototype.js
fully from our site.
So now we have two frameworks.
They both download.
They're both still in use.
And this actually causes
some really strange bugs
in older IE, where you
don't have a get elements
by class name.
Prototype.js would
add one, and jQuery
will detect it and use it.
It returns prototype
objects and jQuery says,
I have no idea what
these are, and fails.
So 2012 also marked the end
of life for this proprietary
build system.
We basically
migrated to a system
that mirrored our entire
SPN repositories via Hudson.
We wrote a new script to
concatenate these CSS imports.
We needed feature parity
with what we had before.
So we had to write
something new to make sure
that we could handle it for the
homepage, which already had it.
It does have all these
features, although CSSLint
is added on the list to
catch syntax errors that
didn't exist until
2012, I believe.
It uses YUI Compressor
to do minification,
and also has to be run manually.
So again, it's really just
limited to the homepage.
So finally, I'm going to
talk a bit about some efforts
in modern times of
what we're trying
to do to really
fix this problem.
So we were really gifted
a very rare opportunity
by the business.
In March, 2013, the
"New York Times"
announced that it was going
to introduce a new article
redesign.
For us, it's more than
just a new user interface
and a new user experience.
It's really a
technological reboot.
We've changed everything
about our systems
in order to deal with some
of these legacy issues
that we've had.
So the best thing-- and I have
an exclamation point here.
And it really doesn't represent
our excitement by this.
We have dynamic pages now.
We no longer have to deal
with an unknown number
of permutations.
We can actually
change our asset URLs
on the fly to bypass the cache
as soon as we do a deploy.
We pushed a lot of
the user customization
into the client side.
We're not doing
it on the server,
so we can actually cache our
pages better on the backend.
We introduced HTML 5 Boilerplate
and Modernizr to give us
a nice starting point
for these new pages.
So now we have a modern
build system using Grunt.
It can be run both in
our developer sandboxes
and in Hudson to
prepare a build.
And most of these
web performance
best practices are actually
available as Grunt tasks
already, which
made it really easy
to integrate some of this
great advice for our code.
We're using RPM packaging
for deployments.
They have very great
rollback support,
and they're really easy to use.
So for style development,
we switched to using LESS.
LESS itself handles
concatenation.
Minification is supported
by YUI Compressor
through the Grunt task.
So this was really easy
to get, these two wins.
Variables and mixins allow us
to do some really interesting
things in CSS that we had
to do with images before.
Arrows, buttons, data
URIs, and spriting.
So earlier this year,
I wrote a Grunt task
that automates the
creation of spritesheets.
I don't really know
what the diction
is around sprites
and spritesheets.
And I don't know.
What do you call the individual
images in a spritesheet?
I have no idea.
So I'm making up
the terminology.
Basically, the task takes in
a bunch of images and exports
not only the
combined spritesheet,
but also a bunch
of mixins and LESS
with the background coordinates,
which makes it not only
really easy to make these
combined images-- you don't
have to maintain them manually--
it's really easy for developers
to use them in the code.
The mixins are named
after the image itself,
so you just put the image
name and you basically
get the sprite.
And the best part about
it is if the coordinates
change because we've added a new
image, and if it's alphabetical
and you added a C, right?
And all the images shift
a little bit, right?
All you have to do is
rebuild the system,
and all the coordinates
are updated.
Nobody has to go in and actually
figure something out and change
anything.
And we're currently
combining about I
think over 100 small
images into one.
That's 99 saved requests
to very small files
that we need for our new design.
I'm not showing it here.
You can check out the marketing
page to see what it looks like.
Just a heads up.
For JavaScript, we
switched to RequireJS.
This handles, again,
concatenation and minification
in the Grunt task.
And we also get
source maps, which
is something we're
really excited to use
for our development.
We no longer need
a global namespace.
That's why the slide
is titled that we're
deleting our
window.nytd namespace.
We get asynchronous
loading of JavaScript.
And we basically decided
to focus on larger
build files so that
once you've established
a connection on mobile,
you want to make sure
you keep the latency low.
That the initial handshake
can be really high.
So we keep these large
build files around instead
of using a bunch of
individual RequireJS loads.
Since we moved a lot of
the client customization
to the browser,
we needed to make
sure we could template properly.
So we use Underscore
JS Templates
instead of building with
the DOM or any HTML strings.
And its way faster
to precompile.
You're essentially running
a JavaScript function,
which is optimized
in the browser.
Grunt can automate this
compilation as a built-in task
to do it.
And we turn them into
a RequireJS module
that gets included as
part of our build process.
So we use Backbone to organize
everything into modules.
They are reusable and they
are shared across applications
if we would like them to be.
But the real win is
that they give us
a bunch of inherited
functionality.
So we can abstract out
touch events and analytics
or some common element
references so that we can--
we won't have to look
them up all the time,
and we can get this
functionality and everything
very easily.
We get event delegation,
fewer event listeners,
so things run a
little more smoothly.
And the modules communicate
with each other using events,
so you can publish
events or you can
subscribe to another
module's events
to find out about changes.
So this is the big topic.
What do we do about ads?
We took ads out of
the critical path.
What we do is on DOM ready,
we write the ad markup
into a new IFrame.
You just take the
frame's document,
and you document.write
it into the frame.
And what happens if the ad
itself calls document.write,
you don't lose your whole page.
You would just lose the
content of the IFrame, which
is blank to begin with.
So we don't care what they
do once they're in the frame,
once they load.
If they decide to bust out
of the frame, they can.
But we have this notion of
trusted ads that aren't framed.
And trusted basically means
that they specifically
don't do things that
are bad for page speed.
And also if there's actually a
problem, it's very easy for us
to get in touch with
them and make the change.
And this has been really,
really effective for us.
So this is the results page.
I thought it would
be great to show you
a comparative slide
of our waterfalls
to show you how really
dramatic this is.
We're not quite ready to show
you that information yet.
It's still being built, so we're
not quite ready to do that.
But to give you an overview.
Before starting to
render the page,
it used to download
over 60 requests.
It's about 10 now,
maybe even fewer.
Before we're fully loaded, we
had to download 200 assets.
It's about 70 now.
Start render is under
one second in Chrome,
and document complete is
under three seconds in Chrome.
So this is a huge win for us.
Before, previously,
document complete
would be about nine seconds
on our article pages.
So to answer Steve's
question about
is web performance
too hard, no and yes.
It's really not that hard.
The optimization
practices are really not
that difficult to begin with.
And there's excellent tooling
that exists to make it really,
really, really easy to do.
However, there are
some unique challenges
that I think not
just big websites,
but companies tend to have
their own challenges that people
can't solve their
problems for them.
And not to mention any legacy
decisions such as ours, where
we have our static pages
that was holding us back.
We found that we did this
negative feedback cycle.
We had this bad,
this poor setup.
And we tried to this proprietary
fix to make it better.
And we found ourselves slightly
worse off than we were before,
even though we were getting
slightly faster speed.
So here's some stuff that we
learned, share some advice.
It's really worth
it to fight to solve
these big, difficult problems.
They are the 800 pound gorilla
in the room for a reason.
Fight to solve them.
Once they're out of
your way, it really
opens the path to making
this a lot simpler.
We live in a world
where you don't
have to rely on proprietary
systems anymore.
You might need some
because it's your business,
so you may need to
make sure that you
have all your requirements
taken care of.
But a lot of the tooling is
just to make this very simple.
I always say that you
should HTTP connections
before you count
bytes in every file.
Do the big easy wins first.
It's really easy to
combine files together
than it is to figure
out what code is old
and needs to be removed
from your files.
And automate everything.
As soon as you introduce
manual to the equation,
it really doesn't get done.
So if you can
automate everything,
it's by far going to pave the
road and make it really easy.
So that's it.
I think I'm running out of time.
Thank you very much
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]?
ETIAN KONIGSBURG: I don't think
I have time for questions.
But I will be around at dinner,
so if you want to come find me.
And I can talk endlessly
about this, so please find me.
I will share all
of my knowledge.